I don't know anything about hungry but I
know I'm really hungry right now his
Hungarians are they the bad guys in
Mulan don't even Gary I'm Gary anything
I've ever heard of it the hungarian
horntail like i wouldn't be able to find
it on a map I don't know what the
cuisine is well I'd better learn to like
this because my girlfriend's in Gary and
her family expects a lot bring on them
the munchies gooey ash nebbish go your
sleeves sleeves you just dip it Bronco
yeah
yeah I think yeah cause it ain't
accident thing oh yeah oh yeah sure
sounds like goulash wow that was really
good it's like homemade from your mom oh
my god I love sour cream am I supposed
to stir it in or am I supposed to have
like a nice sour cream chunk I know it
sounds gross to say liquidy baked potato
it's just got 20 times better duck apple
stuff if you otaku pasta that's what it
just looks like it's going like this as
a child you're never gonna ask for this
mama can I have the top Kappa totes aha
it kind of looks like a big egg roll oh
there's meat there's meat in everything
it doesn't have to the bitterness of a
carriage I think it's because the way
it's cooked it's not that easy to eat
kind of all falls apart mmm don't don't
gobble stuff cheer Kappa Prakash no
candy : Adi these are just Game of
Thrones characters yeah he died in the
second season so my day
you sound like Borat are these the
noodles wait this is how it looks like
little itty-bitty brains no I hate
pickles this was okay that's what it is
it's coleslaw fact I just got had like
the Hungarian KFC it's a little sweet
this is so good
even though I've had all of these things
individually before like noodles and
chicken and
pickled what Evers not I know it tastes
like this before you better like this
food because we need a visitor parents
you're gonna have to be like that glow
from shrinking was delicious sila
masculine boots oh this is so easy
she'll s come back I've had Sylvia's
good luck before sales vos Sylvia the
Goomba
sounds like a sweet Bond villain wow it
smells delicious it smells like a churro
it's very powdery oh look at that
your chocolate oh it's like a berry oh
it's a plum it's kind of bland it's like
British this is a great way to make
children be quiet
tastes like crumbled bread guy had never
previously tried any Hungarian food and
I'm hungry so bad now it's so good I
felt very hearty I feel like I could be
like a lumberjack in the cold forest and
then just come to my cabin have
Hungarian food waiting for me the color
palette of the food was very similar I
think they nail like the savory best
taste test
but wasn't one the best taste as I've
ever been in yeah you would have gotten
that plum garbage or what it was the
actual best
[Music]